[Musique]
on m'amène donc dans mon dans mon
bâtiment et dans ce bâtiment la première
vue est absolument effroyable ça m'a
fait penser à une série américaine qui
s'appelait Prison Break quand
la caricature de la prison
sud-américaine et c'était ça
c'est-à-dire on est à la campagne
c'est-à-dire il pleut les Scorpions
rentre dans les bâtiments des Scorpions
des cafards
ils sont partis pour des vacances ou
pour travailler mais le retour au pays
est devenu très compliqué ils sont des
milliers de Français à être incarcérés à
travers le monde dans des pays dont il
ne connaissent parfois ni les lois ni
les usages Déborah et Jean-Louis deux
destins bouleversés par la prison la
première étant prisonnée depuis plus
d'un an à l'île Maurice le second vient
de quitter les jaules cubaines où il
purgeait une peine de 15 ans que ces
détenus soient coupables ou pas leur
combat ou celui de leurs proches m'a
touché j'ai voulu savoir comment il
trouve l'énergie d'avancer et comment il
tente de vivre aujourd'hui
je m'appelle Jean-Louis Autret j'ai été
incarcéré pendant cinq ans à Cuba
je m'appelle Elisabeth d'Anglas ma nièce
est incarcérée et condamné à 17 ans de
prison à l'île Maurice
comment se battre pour prouver son
innocence quand on est à des milliers de
kilomètres comment agir dans un pays
étranger et composé avec une langue que
l'on ne connaît pas que faire quand les
lois de l'autre pays sont très
différentes
Deborah a quitté la France pour quelques
semaines Jean-Louis est parti
s'installer à l'étranger bloqué à
l'autre bout du monde leurs proches vont
vivre dans l'angoisse et l'impuissance
en attendant leur hypothétique retour
[Musique]
il est 16h30 lors de la sortie des
classes
Jean-Louis est en route pour aller
chercher son fils à l'école un moment
qu'il ne raterait sous aucun prétexte
ça paraît incroyable c'est le vrai
plaisir
d'attendre mon fils devant l'école de
faire des choses normales
des instants de vie qui peuvent sembler
banal mais pour ce papa c'est encore un
moment privilégié auquel il s'habitue à
peine et donc la maîtresse elle était
contente aujourd'hui elle t'a pas fait
de remarques
tu sais ce qu'on va faire on va aller
acheter un petit pain au chocolat
mais toi tu aimes pas alors il profite
au maximum des instants magiques qu'il a
imaginé pendant presque cinq ans loin de
son fils
pour moi aujourd'hui oui c'est ça c'est
les petites choses simples qui me font
prendre conscience
du bonheur de vivre d'être avec sa
famille de ce qu'on aime tout simplement
[Musique]
si Jean-Louis a encore du mal à réaliser
son bonheur c'est qu'il n'a pas vécu
avec ses proches ces dernières années
cela ne fait que deux semaines qu'il est
rentré chez lui
attention
à prendre la poésie par coeur
Jean-Louis a passé les 20 dernières
années de sa vie dans les Caraïbes et
c'est à Cuba qui l'a rencontré sa
nouvelle femme yaima et qu'ils ont eu
ensemble ce petit garçon de 8 ans 7 8
[Musique]
pendant 15 ans Jean-Louis mène une vie
paisible sur l'île de Cuba il s'occupe
de business florissant aussi bien dans
le conseil que dans l'apport export on a
créé avec mon associé une société
d'investissement lui apportait le
capital moi je n'étais que le
vice-président exécutif de cette société
très rapidement on s'est rendu compte
que les cumains ne cherchaient pas
d'investisseurs ils cherchez des gens
qui leur prêtaient de l'argent et qui
leur apportaient un peu de savoir-faire
tout simplement donc c'était notre
activité ensuite moi titre personnel
j'ai monté une petite boîte
d'import-export et une agence de voyage
parce que c'était mon passé et pour la
passion de la mer j'aurais parlé des
bateaux mais ça c'était vraiment titre
quasiment de loisirs une vie calme et
tranquille jusqu'à un certain jour de
2009 un jour qui aujourd'hui encore
reste gravée dans sa mémoire un matin 7
avril 2009
j'embrasse mon épouse je prends ma
voiture je fais les le kilomètre qui me
séparent de mon bureau j'arrive à mon
bureau je prends le café avec mes
collaboratrices tout va bien on fait le
point de la journée des affaires de
l'actualité en gros de Cuba je vois
arriver trois personnes trois hommes qui
marchent en triangle d'un pas très
décidé vers le jardin volonté et ils
arrivent TTI monsieur Audrey on peut
vous parler mais bien entendu monter
dans mon bureau je vous en prie on monte
dans le bureau et à ce moment-là je
ferme la porte et asseyez-vous vos
bureaux les mains sur le bureau vos
codes d'ordinateur vos codes de
téléphone
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe expliquez-moi
ne bougez pas on est d'accord vous êtes
dans mon bureau expliquez-moi monsieur
Audrey ne bougez pas arrive deux autres
ils sont 5 arrivent deux autres ils sont
7 ne bougez pas ils prennent les
ordinateurs après les téléphones je
comprends plus rien je comprends plus
rien finalement pour m'arrêter et
arrêter mes entreprises c'est une
arrestation qui a de mobilisé 65
personnes et donc
là votre vie bascule
en cinq minutes
Jean-Louis vient d'être arrêté sans
savoir pourquoi il est conduit au Centre
d'Investigation de la police cubaine
pendant plusieurs jours sa famille
n'aura aucune nouvelle de lui
[Musique]
vous êtes porte-parole du ministère des
Affaires étrangères comment est-ce que
ça se passe lorsque vous apprenez au
Quai d'Orsay car ressortissant français
est emprisonné à l'étranger alors en
général c'est plutôt une ambassade ou un
consulat général qui est prévenu à la
demande d'une personne qui vient d'être
arrêtée et placée en détention à
l'étranger et qui souhaitent bénéficier
de la protection consulaire alors
qu'est-ce que c'est l'heure que cette
protection consulaire dont vous parlez
alors cette protection elle est encadrée
par le droit international il y a une
convention la Convention de Vienne qui a
été très largement signée et ratifiée
par un très grand nombre d'États dans le
monde et qui donne un certain nombre de
droits et qui fixent un certain nombre
de principes dans l'exercice par les
États de la protection consulaire est-ce
qu'il y a une procédure type chaque pays
assez spécificités nous devons respecter
la souveraineté de chaque État donc nous
demandons pas de traitement préférentiel
pour nos compatriotes mais nous
souhaitons qu'un certain nombre de
droits fondamentaux soit respecté donc
nous assistons parfois aux audiences
devant les tribunaux
donc nous suivons la procédure
judiciaire dans le droit de visite suivi
de la procédure judiciaire et lien avec
la famille lorsque la personne détenue
le souhaite que vous avez des chiffres
de nombre de Français emprisonnés à
l'étranger alors le chiffre global des
français détenus à l'étranger c'est 2200
et sur ces 2200 personnes détenues à
l'étranger 40 % le son pour des
infractions à la législation sur les
stupéfiants pour nous toutes les
personnes méritent la protection et nous
nous mobilisons de façon identique et
avec le même engagement pour chaque
personne quel que soit le pays concerné
[Musique]
Jean-Louis ne se rend pas encore compte
que c'est un combat de plusieurs années
qui s'engagent aussi bien pour lui que
pour sa famille
[Musique]
banlieue ouest de Paris c'est ici
qu'habite Elisabeth avec son fils
pendant plusieurs années elle a aussi
partagé l'appartement avec sa nièce
Déborah la jeune femme était venue
habiter ici pour suivre une formation
dans la ville voisine
tu peux aller chercher les lettres et
les photos de Déborah merci
dans ce classeur la famille conserve
précieusement tous les courriers reçus
de la jeune fille des courriers et
beaucoup de souvenirs
affranchis depuis la prison pour femme
de l'île Maurice ces lettres à
l'écriture maladroite décorée de petits
cœurs sont toutes signées du même prénom
Déborah
bonjour ma tata j'espère que tu vas bien
que tu gardes la forme malgré cette
grande déception j'espère que tu vas
bien à la maison et si c'est pas facile
mais on verra quelque chose de toi je
suis là de jeunes ici jamais j'aurais
préféré
je pense fort à ta nièce Déborah depuis
qu'elle avait accueilli Déborah à la
maison Elisabeth était restée très
présente dans la vie de la jeune fille
déscolarisés depuis la troisième elle
s'inquiétait de ses mauvaises
fréquentations et n'avait pas manqué de
lui faire savoir dès le départ si elle
m'a vu écouter et qu'elle aurait qu'elle
avait arrêté de traîner avec ces filles
là peut-être qu'elle serait pas rentrée
dans un engrenage qui l'aurait emmené
vers des gens peu loyaux et qu'ils l'ont
emmené au là où elle est aujourd'hui
dans ce paradis qui est devenu un enfant
au printemps 2012 Elisabeth ni même
personne de la famille ne s'imagine ce
que s'apprête à faire Déborah
prétextant un départ en vacances avec
des amis à l'île Maurice la jeune femme
de 18 ans sans revenu qui ne vit déjà
plus avec sa famille prend l'avion
précipitamment
elle vient d'accepter un contrat très
dangereux en échange de vacances tout
frais payés l'une de ses connaissances
lui demande de placer dans son sac une
quantité importante de Subutex un
produit considéré comme un stupéfiant à
l'île Maurice
le 23 mars 2012 Elisabeth reçoit un coup
de fil paniqué de la mère de Déborah
sa nièce vient d'être interpellé à 10000
km de chez elle
j'étais dans le bus je sortais de mon
travail et puis mon téléphone a sonné
c'était ma sœur qui disait qui hurlait à
l'autre bout du fil en me disant Déborah
s'est fait arrêter à l'île Maurice
elle criait elle était désespérée
tellement que je n'ai pas compris sur le
moment ça a été un cas au total je me
suis dit il faut faire quelque chose
elle a un avocat on peut
lui trouver quelque chose on peut
appeler quelqu'un elle m'a dit non on
peut rien faire pour le moment donc
tu es un jour
qui je pense restera gravé dans nos
dans notre tête longtemps
à son arrivée à l'aéroport de Plaisance
Déborah a été placé en détention les
douaniers trouvent 6.90 comprimés de
Subutex dans son bagage ce produit
utilisé pour le sevrage des héroïnomanes
est considéré en France comme un
médicament mais sur l'île Maurice c'est
une drogue dont l'usage et le trafic
sont durement réprimés
Déborah ne le sait pas encore mais elle
est victime d'un ou plusieurs réseaux
bien organisés
vous êtes avocat spécialiste du droit
international c'est vous qui défendez
Déborah d'Anglas quel est le profil type
des victimes c'est généralement des
jeunes ou des jeunes femmes plus souvent
des femmes d'ailleurs perdus en période
de post-adolescence ou de enfin de crise
encore adolescente et à qui on fait
miroiter un ou deux voyages à l'île
Maurice tout frais payés en gros 15
jours de vacances avec un petit peu
d'argent de poche sur place voilà c'est
un réseau qui est important un trafic
important
les chiffres précis il y a pas eu
d'études sur des chiffres précis ce qui
est certain c'est que on estime à
plusieurs centaines de milliers ma
consommation de tablettes de Subutex sur
les de Maurice par an ça va donc dire
oui énormément de mules de structure
d'organisation et ça veut donc dire des
des réseaux transnationaux
internationaux donc là n'est pas un cas
isolé et j'imagine que les autorités
sont au courant
n'est pas un cas isolé il y a plusieurs
au moins une dizaine de français détenus
à l'île Maurice pour trafic de Subutex
donc des mules à chaque fois des niveaux
plus ou moins importants il y a deux
types de mules les personnes qui savent
qu'elles transportent des médicaments et
les autres c'est un produit qui est
légal en France que l'on peut trouver en
France qui est un médicament pas en
vente libre mais qui est un médicament
en revanche à Maurice c'est considéré
comme une drogue comme un produit
stupéfiant et qui engendre des peines
extrêmement lourdes donc que les
personnes que les mules sachent quelque
chose c'est très probable qu'elle sache
ce qu'elle transporte et ce qu'elles
encourent en transportant c'est à mon
avis beaucoup moins probable
[Musique]
en attente d'un procès Deborah est
immédiatement incarcéré et elle n'est
pas la seule beaucoup de jeunes femmes
sont utilisées comme des mules pour
alimenter le marché mauricien de la
drogue Déborah risque de se faire
condamner à une peine de prison très
importante
[Musique]
port de plaisance de la Bastille à Paris
de sa passion pour les bateaux
Jean-Louis garde un souvenir amer
c'est en effet à cause de la vente d'un
voilier à Cuba que sa vie a basculé
[Musique]
au début de l'année 2004 j'ai trouvé un
bateau qui était à moitié abandonné sur
la Marine à mingway et pour essayer
d'attirer mon frère vers La Havane je
lui proposais le bateau il l'a acheté
c'était un bateau qui faisait 15 mètres
un voilier de croisière bon qui
correspondait pas obligatoirement à nos
goûts mais bon c'était vraiment une très
très belle opération parce que on a pu
le toucher dans un très bon prix et
quelques mois plus tard des acheteurs
français m'ont contacté parce qu'il
recherchait un bateau à peu près dans
ses caractéristiques là et donc
ils se sont intéressés au bateau mon
frère a décidé de
d'utiliser ce bateau pendant l'été 2004
et de le revendre après et c'est au mois
de juin à Paris en compagnie de son
frère que Jean-Louis va rencontrer les
acheteurs pour finaliser les conditions
de vente du voilier le Tobago Clipper
des hommes un peu bedonnant la
soixantaine très sympathique on
sur les bateaux ils nous ont expliqué
qu'ils étaient un groupe
d'anciens retraités du bâtiment qui
avait travaillé beaucoup à l'étranger
qui avait une petite cagnotte à
l'étranger et qui voulait passer
quelques jours sur leur bateau un peu en
participation et faire de la plongée on
les avait appelé les papilles plongeurs
en septembre à La Havane Jean-Louis est
prêt à conclure la session du bateau
mais au moment d'officialiser la vente
les papilles plongeurs lui font une
étrange proposition au dernier moment la
veille ils m'ont avertit donc il payait
non pas une partie en cash mais que il
paierait en espèces donc tout le solde
du bateau soit près de 200 000 euros
200000 euros soit 260000 dollars
Jean-Louis ne peut pas accepter une
telle offre il prend conseil auprès de
son avocat et sa banque cubaine lui
demande quelques jours pour vérifier
l'origine des fonds 10 jours après la
banque m'a rappelé en me disant avec eux
nous avons fait une enquête sur la
société de des acheteurs il n'y a pas de
problème vous pouvez encaisser l'argent
et cet argent vous pouvez le mettre sur
les comptes en banque
un an plus tard en septembre 2005
Jean-Louis découvre sur internet que son
ancien voilier et ses nouveaux
propriétaires ont été interceptés en mer
avec plusieurs tonnes de cocaïne à bord
je me suis aperçu qu'il faisait venait
d'être arrêté au large des îles du
Cap-Vert avec près de trois tonnes de
cocaïne à bord de du bateau sur le coup
le choc fut tel que je ne pouvais pas
croire que c'était entre guillemets mais
pas piplongeur qui s'était transformé en
trafiquant de Rome
Jean-Louis ne s'inquiète pas le bateau
ne lui appartient plus depuis plusieurs
années ce qui l'ignore c'est que depuis
deux ans des policiers cubains le
surveillent au plus près
et en réalité de 2007 à 2009 7 avril
2009 date à laquelle j'étais arrêté ils
m'ont suivi à Cuba ils ont mis des
micros dans mon bureau ils ont mis des
micros dans ma chambre ils ont mis des
micros dans ma salle de réunion dans ma
voiture partout partout ils ont écouté
tous nos téléphones cellulaires fixe etc
ils nous ont tous écouté pendant deux
ans
et non rien trouvé
mais c'est un vieux mail de 2004 qui va
déclencher les poursuites judiciaires
à l'époque au moment de l'achat du
voilier Jean-Louis a voulu se montrer
très persuasif avec l'ancien
propriétaire norvégien et lui prouvé sa
passion de la voile un moment donné pour
lui montrer que je suis quelqu'un de
sérieux et je lui explique que j'ai un
bateau de 70 pieds et j'y mets ayave
seventy 70 pieds
Astérix catama seventy catamaran ça a
été traduit par la police française et
là je dis bien la police française et
non pas par la police cubaine il a 70
catamaran
incatamaran c'est 200 300 000 dollars un
bateau
ils sont lisses ça y est jackpot on
tient le gros lot une erreur de
traduction qui aura des conséquences
terribles à Paris les membres de la
famille de Jean-Louis sont placés en
garde à vue
rapidement les enquêteurs français se
rendent compte de leur erreur
acuba c'est trop tard Jean-Louis est
arrêté et incarcéré
[Musique]
en 2013 le verdict tombe pour Déborah la
nièce d'Elizabeth
à 19 ans elle est jugée et écope d'une
peine de 17 ans de prison pour trafic de
drogue une peine encourue lorsque la
valeur des stupéfiants transportés
dépasse 25000 euros sur l'île Maurice au
cours de son procès elle reconnaît avoir
déjà introduit des boîtes de médicaments
quelques mois auparavant en novembre
je me tire non c'est pas possible 17 ans
dans combien de temps va la revoir
aujourd'hui Elisabeth vient voir sa sœur
Rebecca c'est la mère de Déborah elle se
retrouve pour discuter avec la jeune
femme par webcam depuis la prison
Rebecca a été très affaibli par
l'arrestation de sa fille elle compte
beaucoup sur Elisabeth pour l'aider à
avancer dans le dossier les deux soeurs
doivent pourtant se résoudre à observer
la situation à distance impuissante on
n'a pas vu Déborah depuis le 23 mars
2012 date de son arrestation l'aéroport
de Maurice par la brigade anti-drogue et
que ce soit moi ou l'ensemble de ma
famille même si on avait voulu la voir
depuis l'avocat nous l'a déconseillé
nous disons que on ne s'accepterait pas
sur le territoire mauricien je suis
vraiment très très en colère parce que
de pas pouvoir être là en tant que mère
de pouvoir la rassurer la voir de visu
lui dire que je suis là et me battre
pour elle en étant sur place
et
j'ai vraiment une rage profonde
deux fois par mois la famille a le droit
à des rendez-vous internet avec la jeune
fille une façon pour sa mère de pallier
son absence
me disant que Skype ça me permet de
communiquer avec elle de voir vraiment
quelle en bonne santé de voir son visage
et ses expressions comme si elle était
en face de moi chose que que je ne peux
pas voir au téléphone les appels sont
gérés par le personnel de la prison les
créneaux sont serrés et les échanges
durent entre 15 et 30 minutes seulement
mais comme tu remarques là
les deux dernières fois mais s'appelle
et sont pas excédés un quart d'heure 30
il est midi depuis plusieurs heures
Elizabeth et sa soeur essaie d'entrer en
contact avec Déborah
une procédure compliquée à laquelle
elles ont du mal à s'habituer
je me connais je demande à parler à
Déborah et là j'attends leur bon vouloir
soit elle me répondent que il y a déjà
quelqu'un
et qu'il faut que je patiente soit ils
vont me dire rien du tout et je vais
attendre avec Skype branché jusqu'à tant
que la prison appelle
donc c'est vraiment aléatoire comme je
vous dis tout dépend la personne qui
s'occupe de Skype ce jour-là
c'est eux qui choisissent en fin de
compte on est tributaire de leur bonne
humeur aujourd'hui malgré le rendez-vous
fixé de longue date Déborah ne se
connectera pas depuis le compte de la
prison pour femme de bobassins
aucune explication ne sera apportée aux
deux femmes
[Musique]
il y a un décalage et quand vous êtes là
que vous avez attendu la séance pendant
deux semaines et que elle peut pas se
produire
il y a de quoi vraiment et tout le monde
comme moi en pleurer c'est rageant très
rarement
Élisabeth aussi a le sentiment de ne
rien pouvoir partager avec sa nièce quel
que soit le moyen de communication il y
a pas d'intimité voilà il y a pas
d'intimité si on veut lui écrire une
petite lettre avec des mots d'amour de
la compassion où on se livre nous-mêmes
on est sûr que toute façon elle sera lu
à force de se rater au téléphone de voir
les lettres et les colis ouverts les
deux femmes imaginent le pire sur les
conditions de vie de Déborah donc
finalement l'inquiétude elle est au
quotidien parce que comme vous voyez des
reportages à la télé comme vous voyez
tout ce qui peut se passer que ce soit
dans les prisons à travers le monde je
me dis c'est mon enfant quoi ça se
trouve il doit arriver des choses et que
moi je peux pas le savoir et que elle ne
peut pas me le dire non plus
[Musique]
Elisabeth et sa soeur désigne clairement
les coupables pour elle ce sont les
trafiquants ceux qui sont à la tête des
réseaux et qui ont emmené des beaux ras
loin d'elle aujourd'hui c'est contre eux
qu'elle souhaite mener le combat c'était
une proie facile Déborah c'était
on a profité d'elle de sacrédulité de
son jeune âge qui m'énerve le plus au
monde c'est ces trafiquant qui se
servent de journalif de jeunes filles de
père de famille qui les envoient au
casse-pipe en leur faisant miroiter la
lune et qui eux sont tranquillement chez
eux qui sont pas inquiétés pendant que
des gens moisissent en prison
[Musique]
Déborah n'est pas la seule à avoir été
piégé entre Paris et l'île Maurice
existent un réseau puissant qui mène de
plus en plus de mules à la case prison
un réseau que l'on appelle la Subutex
connection
[Musique]
à La Havane ce 7 avril 2009 la police
cubaine fait de l'arrestation de
Jean-Louis une véritable démonstration
de force pour lui cet instant reste
toujours l'un de ses pires souvenirs à
des moments le pire c'est quand on m'a
mis des menottes
m'a mis des menottes on m'a mis entre
deux gares passé on est rentré dans une
Lada de la police on a roulé à une
vitesse absolument folle avec les
sirènes hurlantes quelque chose de
c'est
je
conduis à la prison de cynaldo un centre
construit par les policiers est allemand
de la Stasi il est placé en garde à vue
et ne comprend toujours pas pourquoi il
est arrêté je pense que quand je suis
arrêté je me suis dit c'est une erreur
il s'est passé quelque chose un moment
donné quand a commencé quand on
commençait les interrogatoires parce que
je sais pas pourquoi ils m'ont jamais
dit il a fallu cinq jours pour me dire
que en réalité on suspectait sept jours
de pour suspecter de trafic de drogue
international
Jean-Louis et confronté à des conditions
de détention qu'il n'avaient jamais
imaginé
au stigmation
il n'a pas idée du système carcéral dans
lequel il vient de tomber des gens qui
rentrent sont condamnés
c'est comme ça
donc j'arrive là dedans
toutes les brimades que vous pouvez
imaginer
pour vous rabaisser d'accord les
techniques sont des techniques de
destruction psychologique ils exploitent
n'importe quelle faille de votre vie en
gros c'est une garde à vue avec des des
moyens invraisemblables est-ce une garde
à vue vous ne savez jamais si elle va
durer une semaine à un mois de moins et
moi dans mon cas ça a été long puisque
ça durait trois mois et demi
Jean-Louis est finalement accusé de
blanchiment d'argent de la drogue
un matin sans être prévenu il est
transféré à La Conte des saints une
prison pour étranger à 90 km de la vanne
au milieu des champs de canne à sucre
on m'amène donc dans mon dans mon
bâtiment et dans ce bâtiment la première
vue est absolument effroyable ça m'a
fait penser à une série américaine qui
s'appelait Prison Break quand
la caricature de la prison
sud-américaine et c'était ça
c'est-à-dire on est à la campagne
c'est-à-dire il pleut les Scorpions
rentre dans les bâtiments des Scorpions
des cafards des des milliers de mouches
[Musique]
Jean-Louis va attendre un an et demi son
procès et c'est par hasard en regardant
la télévision dans sa cellule qu'il
découvre le verdict des juges je suis à
la prison les codes nus m'appelle d'un
seul coup mais Jean-Louis regarde le la
télé les infos et le présentateur local
annonce un français et condamné à 15 ans
la sentence n'est pas sortie ils sont
même pas encore délibérés c'était une
mascarade une nouvelle étape commence
pour lui et sa famille il faut
absolument faire sortir Jean-Louis de
prison avant la fin de sa peine
[Musique]
Daniel tibi le 27 septembre 1995 vous
êtes s’arrêter en Équateur par deux
policiers au départ c'est un simple
contrôle d'immigration puis vous êtes
accusé à tort de trafic de cocaïne
j'imagine que vous vous souvenez de cet
instant comme si c'était hier oui je
faisais mon métier de négocier en pierre
précieuse je me rendais un rendez-vous
quand j'étais arrêté sur le coup j'ai
pas réalisé qui pouvait y avoir des
conséquences aussi dramatiques que celle
qui qui sont produites qu'est-ce qu'on
se dit à ce moment-là ça va s'arrêter
c'est un cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar et le cauchemar il
prend forme et là je me suis retrouvé
dans l'enfer tout a basculé j'ai
découvert que je j'étais pris dans un
engrenage qui me semblait complètement
surréaliste ça se passe comment il y a
un système judiciaire qui qui est
absolument infernal parce que il y a de
la corruption à tous les niveaux et que
pour faire n'importe quoi il faut payer
donc quand vous avez été dépouillés de
tous vos biens et vous n'avez plus un
saut en poche les procédures n'avancent
pas parce qu'il faut payer pour chaque
copie pour chaque acte pour tout
fonctionne avec l'argent vous avez
acheté la protection d'un prisonnier oui
oui au départ j'ai payé pour ma
protection pendant quelques mois et les
gens ont commencé à me laisser
tranquille alors dans le livre 900 jours
900 nuits dans l'enfer d'une pression
équatorienne vous dites que vous avez
demandé à votre femme de vous ramener le
Code civil de l'équateur mais votre
défense elle s'est effectuée comment
j'ai étudié le code pénal et le code de
procédure pendant des mois et des mois
en relevant tous les articles qui
étaient en violation du code de leur
propre constitution ou code pénale et de
donc de mener les recours nécessaires et
puis j'ai réussi à trouver un avocat qui
était moins corrompu que les autres mais
qui avait besoin quand même que je le
paye régulièrement et ensuite au bout
d'un an et demi l'ambassade a commencé à
des comptes et c'est là où ça s'est
accéléré le gouvernement français est
intervenu et de façon assez efficace et
qui a contribué à me faire libérer je
pense que sinon je serais je serai pas
sorti vous évoquez des articles parus
dans la presse française notamment un
article du pèlerin magazine titre on
n'oublie pas vous avez connaissance de
ces articles dans votre cellule oui
quand l'article est paru j'étais enfermé
mais ça m'a donné une lueur d'espoir
c'était ah oui c'était c'est une étoile
qui brille dans dans l'obscurité est-ce
que vous auriez des conseils à donner
aux gens qui voyagent dans ces pays
étrangers où il y a de la corruption oui
ne jamais suivre des policiers
Jean-Louis vient d'être condamné à 15
ans de prison ses proches et plus
particulièrement son frère Jean-Pierre
vont créer un comité de soutien à
Jean-Louis
[Musique]
en cellule Déborah la nièce d'Elizabeth
s'est rapproché d'une autre jeune fille
faranachi
Sarah avait à peu près le même âge
qu'elle lorsqu'elle a été arrêtée en
décembre 2011 pour les mêmes raisons
trafic de Subutex elles ont noué une
relation je dirais plus de soeurs très
protectrice quand Déborah avait peur la
nuit elle allait dans le lit de Farah
donc cette relation qui s'est nouée à
l'île Maurice c'est nouée aussi en
France parce que nous du coup nous avons
rencontré Samira justement aujourd'hui
Elisabeth vient voir Samira la mère de
Farah les deux femmes sont devenus amis
et se voir régulièrement
[Musique]
samira se souvient de sa première
rencontre avec la famille de Déborah je
me suis sentie beaucoup plus forte
beaucoup plus
patiente
bon ça m'a vraiment aidé à survivre
parce que toute seule c'était très très
difficile toute seule je savais pas quoi
faire je voulais mais je savais pas
comment je savais pas comment
et à quelle porte taper
pour Elisabeth et Samira il ne s'agit
pas d'accident isolés Déborah et Farah
sont victimes des réseaux organisés qui
profitent de la candeur de jeunes filles
influençables elle décide d'alerter les
pouvoirs publics en envoyant une lettre
ouverte aux médias sur ce fléau qui
semble se développer qu'on a rencontré
Samira on avait une idée que il y avait
un trafic mais du coup ce que on se
doutait on a pu le dire et l'écrire d'où
est parti notre lettre ouverte ou
là-dessus on disait bien qu'elles
étaient victimes d'un trafic mais il a
fallu vraiment cette rencontre pour
pouvoir l'affirmer mais pour nous on
avait la conviction que elle s'était
fait piéger dès le départ
l'arme principale de ces deux familles
c'est de continuer à alerter l'opinion
publique
Subutex quand un jeune pas au courant de
toute cette histoire
avant supposons par exemple le quelqu'un
lui a proposé la même chose que hafara
est Déborah et s'il voit ça un article
comme ça il sera que ce médicament est
considéré comme de la drogue dure là-bas
on s'est dit que à deux familles on
ferait plus de poids vis-à-vis des
autorités et vis-à-vis même déjà
l'impact qu'on pouvait toucher
auprès des gens en général que plutôt
tout seul parce que en fin de compte on
en parle pas on en a jamais parlé de ce
trafic là et je pense que si on n'est
pas plusieurs à le dénoncer il y a pas
de poids dans la balance donc on a
amassé des choses on a rencontré des
gens donc des fois on s'est fait claquer
la porte au nez
ou on s'est entendu dire que à base
était coupable et que voilà mais voilà
nous on dit les choses comme elles sont
et puis peut-être que en les disant il y
a d'autres jeunes qui se font pas piéger
et justement ça évitera que d'autres
familles souffrent comme nous on souffre
à l'heure actuelle aussi
ce trafic de stupéfiant que dénoncer
Elizabeth et Samira prospère entre Paris
et l'île Maurice
celle qui font le travail de mule on les
appelle les marsannes la mort comprenez
les marchands de morts mais les familles
réfutent cette image elles veulent
garder un souvenir radieux de leurs
enfants leurs filles sont avant tout des
victimes selon elles
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui est le plus compliqué dans
ce type d'affaires en fait dans ces
affaires il y a plusieurs affaires dans
l'affaire il y a le dossier de fond qui
est généralement est géré par des
avocats locaux et ensuite il y a de la
deuxième thématique qui est comment
est-ce que l'on fait sortir ensuite la
personne de prison ou comment est-ce
qu'on l'a rapatrie en France et ce qui
devient compliqué c'est les relations
politiques puisque c'est une décision
purement politique qui est prise entre
deux États plus ou moins balisés par le
droit mais c'est quand même une décision
politique et souvent ces personnes sont
tributaires d'enjeux internationaux
qu'on ne maîtrise pas son tributaire
d'un contrat qui va être signé dont on
veut qu'il soit signé et il y a des
libérations miracles et d'autres qui
mettent énormément de temps faire appel
aux voix politiques et diplomatiques
finalement c'est indispensable
enfin il est pas possible d'agir sans le
soutien de la France sur place et
d'ailleurs en fonction de la valeur ou
de l'implication des soutiens des
consuls locaux les dossiers peuvent se
débloquer plus ou moins facilement et
mettre plus ou moins de temps dans ce
cas est-ce que c'est une bonne solution
de mobiliser l'opinion publique très
souvent en tout cas lorsqu'il y a des
blocages un des moyens de
s'effectivement une mobilisation
publique forte avec par exemple des
sites de pétition en ligne sont des
choses qui se font assez souvent je sais
que par exemple pour Farah et Déborah je
crois qu'on approchait les 20000
signatures ça ne résout pas tout en
quelques instants bien évidemment mais
ça permet un aux personnes de se dire
qu'elles ne sont pas oublier et puis
deux de maintenir un réseau de soutien
financier moraux intellectuel et de
pression pour utiliser un terme qui
fâche
aujourd'hui Jean-Louis retrouve son
frère Jean-Pierre pour faire le point
sur les dossiers en cours allez en route
allez
très proche de son cadet Jean-Pierre se
souvient parfaitement de la première
fois qu'il a revu son frère à Cuba au
début de son incarcération
il était détruit psychologiquement
détruit extrêmement fatigué il avait les
il avait il avait les cheveux qui avait
blanchi en deux mois et extrêmement
émacié et voilà on voyait qu'il était
totalement désiré des orienté
Jean-Pierre et bouleversé par la
situation et c'est en aîné de la famille
qu'il prend en main le destin de son
frère en faisant appel à toutes les
bonnes volontés d'abord on a commencé à
fonctionner avec un cercle dit de 10
intime d'amis intime qui avait des
compétences d'avocats de chefs
d'entreprise et autres parce que ça
permettait d'avoir des idées vous avez
travaillé la boîte à idées
Jean-Pierre s'implique tellement dans
cette mission qu'elle en devient
quasiment un travail à plein temps pour
lui
ça a été un travail énorme il y a eu des
périodes où alors là on était même à
120% et compte tenu des décalages
horaire ça se terminait souvent à 2h du
matin je pense qu'en cinq ans je vais
pas calculer mais j'ai dû faire des
milliers et des milliers de mails etc
j'ai eu des notes de téléphone qui sont
montées entre 500 et 900 euros certains
mois parce que Cuba c'est c'est pas loin
d'un euro la minute et donc voilà dans
les périodes intenses il fallait il
fallait échanger pour essayer de se
préparer
voilà donc ça c'est les dossiers malgré
un comité de soutien qui mobilise près
de 8000 personnes le groupe d'intimes
comprend que sans appui politique il
sera difficile d'obtenir une libération
rapide de Jean-Louis
[Musique]
on est rentré sans faire de politique en
contact avec un certain nombre de
politiques locaux à Lorient ou à Paris
donc les politiques sur la clé de voûte
du système et là le ministère des
Affaires étrangères et la cheville
ouvrière et l'ambassadeur en finale et
l'homme qui agit voilà mais c'est ça
marche dans ce sens là et non pas dans
l'autre sens
ce matin Jean-Louis son épouse et son
frère Jean-Pierre ont rendez-vous dans
le centre de Paris pour une visite à
laquelle ils tiennent particulièrement
pour la première fois depuis sa récente
libération Jean-Louis retrouve une
personne qui a joué un rôle très
important dans son affaire
bonjour bonjour
[Rires]
ministre des Affaires étrangères a pu
rencontrer Jean-Louis dans sa prison de
la Condessa en 2010
ça fait très plaisir de vous voir
très très plaisir on est loin des champs
de cannes là
merci merci c'est la première fois que
l'ancien ministre peut revoir tous les
membres de la famille enfin réunis
je vous vois en super forme tout va bien
et ça désespère des ennemis
parce que Monsieur Dumas a représenté un
le premier qui vraiment si j'ose dire à
mouiller sa chemise s'est investi à
traverser l'Atlantique
a été à La Havane à rencontrer des
dirigeants au cubains et ça m'a apporté
un soutien énorme n'imaginez pas comment
dire l'appui moral que représente une
visite de cette qualité avec vous
commencez à y croire vous dites bon ça
va bouger lors de son séjour Roland
Dumas a rencontré de nombreux
responsables cubains dont le président
du Parlement pour plaider la cause de
Jean-Louis
j'avais compris depuis le début qu'il y
avait tout un aspect juridique
judiciaire comme vous voulez et donc en
s'appuyant sur les relations politiques
et diplomatiques on transposait le
dossier purement judiciaire dans un
procès de négociation politique et puis
petit à petit à force d'insistance à
force de présence d'esprit à force de
communication on est arrivé au résultat
que vous voyez aujourd'hui
[Musique]
Jean-Louis accepte un transfèrement et
une transposition de sa peine en France
en novembre 2013 il quitte le territoire
cubain avec sa femme et son fils de
retour en France il passe deux mois dans
une prison française
Jean-Louis est libéré le 17 janvier 2014
[Musique]
l'histoire de sa nièce a été comme une
révélation pour Elisabeth au-delà du
combat qu'elle mène pour dénoncer les
réseaux elle pense aussi à tous ceux qui
pourraient connaître le même sort que
Déborah des personnes fragiles qui se
mettent parfois en danger sans en saisir
les conséquences
j'ai réalisé peut-être qu'il y avait pas
assez de prévention et qui va aller
faire de la prévention au niveau des
personnes vulnérables des personnes qui
se laisseraient faire miroiter la lune
pour
juste prendre un petit service qui
pourrait leur coûter la vie
surtout que bon là c'est une
condamnation à la prison mais dans
certains pays c'est la condamnation à la
peine de mort donc je voudrais que ça ça
n'arrive plus
est-ce que c'est arrivé dans les
dernières années qu'un Français
souhaitait exécuter à l'étranger sans
que vous puissiez intervenir nous
faisons le maximum pour que cela
n'intervienne pas la majorité des
infractions qui sont commises par les
Français à l'étranger relèvent du trafic
de stupéfiants dans certains pays ce
sont des peines de prison plus ou moins
lourdes plus ou moins longues dans
d'autres pays cela peut aller jusqu'à la
peine de mort selon le Code pénal local
quelle est la marge de manoeuvre du Quai
d'Orsay à l'étranger tout dépend des cas
il y a des cas délicats nous avons par
exemple 8 Français qui sont condamnés à
la peine de mort pour ces cas-là qui
sont évidemment emblématiques
naturellement nous faisons toutes les
démarches nécessaires pour éviter que
cette peine soit exécutée qu'elle soit
commuée parce que nous souhaitons
l'abolition universelle de la peine de
mort et nous avons engagé avec Laurent
Fabius une campagne
auprès de la communauté internationale
pour que les États qui pratiquent encore
la peine capitale y renonce
[Musique]
Elisabeth et sa famille cherchent
maintenant le soutien des plus hautes
instances de l'État elle attend que le
gouvernement français intercède pour
faire avancer le dossier des jeunes
filles là où elle place ses espoirs
notamment c'est dans la procédure de
transfertment un moyen pour les détenus
à l'étranger de venir purger une peine
aménagée en France au mois de juillet on
a déposé la demande de transfert pour
Déborah celle de Farah on a dû attendre
la fin de son jugement pour la déposer
et maintenant ce qu'on espère c'est
qu'elle soit là très prochainement avec
nous
que on puisse rattraper le temps perdu
les nouvelles
où elles étables sont les anniversaires
sans elle puis on espère surtout que les
promesses
de
l'Elysée suite à la lettre qu'on la
dernière lettre qu'on leur a dressée
disons qu'au moment du transfèrement il
nous porterons appui il tiendront leurs
paroles et que il nous aideront à ce que
nos filles soient de retour parmi nous
si le gouvernement français a marqué son
soutien auprès de la famille
rien n'a encore été mis en œuvre pour
que la jeune femme soit de retour auprès
des siens
[Musique]
emprisonné à l'étranger chaque année des
Français se font arrêter à des milliers
de kilomètres de chez eux les sangs
derrière eux leur famille et leurs
proches des œuvres
après cinq années passées en prison
Jean-Louis et libre aujourd'hui il goûte
le plaisir de reconstruire sa vie ici en
France avec sa femme et son fils
il cherche un job sûrement dans l'export
mais il ne veut pas précipiter les
choses et surtout Jean-Louis n'oublie
pas l'immense dette qu'il a contracté
envers tous ceux qui l'ont aidé à sortir
de Cuba surtout son grand frère nous
sommes plutôt je dirais pudique dans la
façon d'exprimer les sentiments et
le rôle d'un grand frère paraît-il c'est
de protéger son petit frère bon ben
voilà
mais j'aurais fait la même chose pour
mon grand frère donc
c'est très fort pour Elisabeth et sa
famille la situation se dessine
doucement un accord bilatéral existe
entre la France et l'île Maurice qui
devrait permettre à Déborah de terminer
sa peine dans l'Hexagone mais sans date
de retour encore fixée et si Elisabeth
reconnaît qu'avec la meilleure volonté
du monde il est parfois difficile de ne
pas se décourager elle veut avant tout
penser aux autres parents c'est un drame
mais c'est de l'impuissance parce que
même si on fait des choses même si on a
l'impression
de faire des choses souvent on se dit on
a cette pensée là-bas là on patoche là
il va falloir faire quelque chose
et je crois que
[Musique]
je voudrais pas que ça arrive à
quelqu'un d'autre